Memory churn is a constant
and serious problem
for the performance
of your applications.
Allocating loads of
temporary objects
in a short period
of time puts a ton
of pressure on
your memory heaps,
resulting in more GC
events being kicked off.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And rather than promoting
a bulk of your objects
to static in order to solve
the memory churn problems,
you can utilize an amazingly
powerful data structure
known as an object pool.
Typically, memory churn comes
from creating a whole group
of temporarily resident objects,
like images, or views, paint
objects, and even threads.
They repeatedly get created,
exist for a little while,
and then are freed.
This action ends up
polluting and fragmenting
the memory heap in a very
short amount of time, resulting
in more GC events
being kicked off.
When this happens
on a regular basis,
you end up getting
a hoard of GC events
that occur at a great frequency.
But thankfully, there's a way
to get the same functionality
of the allocation and freeing of
objects without the GC events,
and it's called an object pool.
Effectively, when you're
done with an object,
rather than freeing it
back to the memory heap,
you keep a reference to it in
a list of available objects.
The next time you
need to allocate
an object of that type, you can
repurpose an existing object
from the pool rather than
grabbing a brand new one
from the memory heap.
Only when your pool
is empty does it
make sense to go
back to the heap
to allocate new objects,
which will eventually
be freed back to
the pool, growing
its potential size over time.
The end result of
using an object pool
is that instead of a
ton of heap fluctuation,
you'll end up with stable
allocations or small growths
over time, which, of course,
can lead to less GC events being
kicked off, helping you
save precious frame time.
But object pools are
tricky to get right.
And I have a handful of
implementation caveats
that you need to watch out for.
Firstly, remember that there's
an overhead involved each time
the object pool needs to go back
to the main heap to allocate
memory.
Now it may be small,
but it's there,
and you should watch out for it.
As such, rather than allocating
an object each time one is
needed, it makes more
sense to allocate
a group of free
objects at one time
so that the overhead
is mitigated
for future allocations.
In addition, rather than waiting
for each empty pool request
to make a new heap allocation,
instead fill your pool
with objects at
application load time
so the first group of objects
you're grabbing from the pool
are as fast as possible.
With a little statistics
gathering here,
you could even figure out the
ideal preallocation amount
so that you can fill
your pool ahead of time,
minimizing the number of times
you have to go back to the heap
during the lifetime
of your application.
However, one of the
downsides of objects pools
is that now you, the programmer,
are responsible for allocating
and freeing objects manually
back to the object pool, which
is a pattern that
very much resembles
non-garbage collected languages.
So you might want to limit
the usage of object pools
to high churn object
sets that demand
this level of interaction.
Otherwise, you'd
be wasting a lot
of features of the Java
garbage collected language.
And finally, in order to make
sure that all of your objects
are returned to
the pool properly,
make sure that member
variables of these objects
are properly cleaned up
so that it doesn't contain
any references to any other
objects in memory that
might be valid for the garbage
collector to clean up later.
If you're not careful
here, you can end up
creating a lot of
persistent memory leaks
for these objects in your pools.
There's some intuition involved
with finding the right places
for these object pools.
But if you're ever in doubt or
looking for new opportunities,
you can use the allocation
tracker tool in Android Studio
to identify any
areas where you may
be seeing a horde of
similar object types coming
from roughly the same call stack
in a very short period of time.
This is a classic sign
of memory thrashing
and easy to see that
it's the right place
to start with object pools.
Anyhow, using object
pools are a great way
to reduce memory churn and
grab back critical performance
resources.
But like anything
else, this feature
comes with a tradeoff
in additional code
that makes it happen.
If you're interested in other
tradeoffs for performance,
make sure you check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns content and join our
Google+ page for more tips from
other great developers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]